[Music]
tommy carey welcome to how the light
gets in thank you so one of the things
you said is that no one wants to admit
that race is real what do you mean by
that
well i think that in their social
constructionism people have thought that
race is
an illusion something that can be
admitted or not admitted talked about or
not spoken about
and somehow that decreases its power
when i say that people don't think that
it's real
they don't think that it organizes
society that it affects the way that
people perceive the world
that in many ways it determines the life
course of people who are affected by
race whether or not you're white black
asian indigenous hispanic latino etc
very much affects the course of your
life trajectory even your life
expectancy in some cases
and i think particularly in the uk that
seems to have a cultural predilection
towards colorblindness it's very
dangerous habit because it assumes that
the failures of certain groups of people
are based on collective individual
pathologies that these are individuals
choosing to not succeed choosing to
endorse the wrong kinds of values rather
than seeing how certain structures forms
of education
economic and political barriers
obscure the ability of people to not
only see and pursue certain courses of
life in action but also become rewarded
as their white counterparts for
retaining the getting the same kind of
education are the same kind of jobs so
is it then connected to this distinction
that people sometimes make between
whether race is a sort of
structural social
problem and an institutional problem
versus whether race is a
as you said a sort of fault of certain
individuals who just need to be
therapized out of their biases yes
absolutely absolutely and i think this
is what you'll find when you read
something like the black radical
tradition or critical race theory or
even afro-pessimism contemporary black
theory about racism versus you know
mainstream liberal theory liberal theory
suggests that race or racism is an
individual bias it's a cognitive you
know prejudice that people have that
they read people based on skin color and
not who they are is autonomous free
rational individuals so in that sense
people say well look this is something
that we need to adjust people's mindsets
or their psychologies from which is why
most of the decolonization discussion in
the uk focuses on how you make white
people better people how do you allow
white people to see diversity and see
that there's different colors of people
and complexions that have contributed to
world history
when you're looking at black
intellectual traditions you're looking
at racism as a form of dehumanization as
a process that's been engaged upon
deliberately by european countries by
nations by structures by institutions
meant to denigrate and exploit certain
groups of people for the benefit of the
white race and it's that kind of
distinction between people who
experience racism and develop theories
just talk concretely about how it what
it is how it acts how it affects people
that are burdened with racialization and
then white liberals who think often that
oh well it's just about me endorsing the
right kind of black person or
recognizing that black
as a people cultural historical process
and racism merely as an individual bias
another kind of approach to
thinking about race
is intersectionality yes and it's the
idea that
we only really understand race through
this kind of overlap with other
identities like gender or
class
um
and that's where the true nature and
extent of like different forms of
oppression become visible
you've been a critic of some of those
approaches what's your what's your
thought why do you think that approach
is also problematic well i mean there's
so much to say about that i think from a
historical perspective we often ignore
that
the rubric of anti-discrimination law in
the united states that intersectionality
is based on which is largely title vii
jurisprudence um it's a contingent and
constructed phenomena the addition of
sex to title vii jurisprudence of
legislation was the effect of the
national women's party a conservative
feminist organization uh actually trying
to stop title seven legislation from
benefiting black people so in order to
kill the legislation they said let's
introduce sex uh to the debates so the
congressional debates show that they
thought they were gonna stop black civil
rights gains affirmative action et
cetera but ended up adding sex and then
redistributing the economic benefits
like affirmative action entrance into
college et cetera from black people who
had marched under civil rights and died
for those rights to white women that's
why we see that after you know the 1960s
and 70s the primary beneficiaries of
affirmative action were white women not
the black people who marched and far
from civil rights in the united states
now taking that as a historical backdrop
you ask yourself what is adding sex a
contingent and really subversive
category uh in title seven legislation
actually due to the identities of people
who suffer well for a long time black
people weren't understood to have gender
they weren't recognized as men and women
most infamously you see the protest
where people black men were marching i
am a man largely because black men were
still referred to as boys especially in
the part of the country in the united
states that i'm from so when we ask
ourselves well there's intersectional
identities well what do those
intersectional identities mean we're
reading history backwards
anachronistically we're assuming that
the identities of man woman male female
masculinity and feminine apply to all
racial groups the same way throughout
history so you take intersectionality as
a concept in the 1980s and you read it
all the way back to the 1860s when black
people were thought to be animals you
know it's it's this kind of lazy
intellectualism that i have a problem
with because we'll adamantly state that
black people weren't seen as humans but
somehow we believe that people respected
their sexual orientation and their
gender identities that seems almost
silly when you say it that way but it
occupies a central place in how most
intellectuals try to re-read and revise
history to fit the idea of the theory i
think one of the most impactful
criticisms that i have in her sexuality
is just many of the intuitions we have
about it are false so when you say
things like race plus class plus gender
you have to really ask yourself what
constitutes the category if you're
thinking about combining race and gender
and you think gender is woman you have
to start asking yourself very empirical
questions well what does that mean
historically that's meant that the idea
that black women seem to suffer both
from racism and sexism and that they
suffer from double jeopardy meaning that
they usually endure worse effects than
black men or their male counterparts
when we look at the empirical evidence
we find that's largely untrue so if you
look at police killings for instance we
find that femininity actually devoid
some of the animus that white people
feel towards black targets when you look
at things like economic progress or
education we see that black women have
slight advantages in those in those
areas in fact when you look at the
category of race itself we find that
most racist stereotypes are attached to
how white people or dominant groups view
the males of that particular racial or
ethnic group and this is what black male
studies scholars mean when they say
racism is centric aggression racism is
primarily a form of discrimination and
violence that targets to ours aims to
target or eliminate males of a certain
racial or ethnic subordinate group so if
we take the social scientific research
into account we don't get the intuitive
the obviousness right that
intersectionality theorist claims exist
when you utilize their ideas or utilize
their methods
on the other hand
it sounds like you want in some ways to
reappropriate
intersectionality or direct it in a
different
direction
by thinking of how black male identity
in particular plays a role and some
feminist scholars have criticized you
for doing this for reappropriating as it
were the this concept of inter
intersectionality when writing about the
racism faced by black males in
particular and how different that is
from the racism faced by black women
sure so what do you make of that
critique and can you tell us about how
you are trying to kind of think of
gender
uh
male gender
in relation to race here yeah i always
find that an interesting critique uh
because i think for some
intersectionality theories there is no
outside of intersectionality even the
criticisms of intersectionality become
intersectionality at some point and i
think one of the most obvious examples
of that is peter quan's analysis
synthesis theory a few decades ago peter
quan suggested that the problem with
intersectionality is that even though it
claimed that it was against essentialism
it decentralizes race and gender into
the idea of the black female subject and
he says well how is that useful if we're
trying to utilize abstract categories to
speak about different aspects or our
variations of identity and social
position so he makes this criticism and
his article on phone synthesis a few
years later suddenly intersectionality
becomes that latino mature says this is
one of the strengths as well as infinite
weaknesses of the theories that any
criticism never becomes the theory and
in my work this is what i meant about
the ad-hoc nature of intersectionality
that anytime i disprove something
empirically or historically show for
instance that many of the claims that
intersectionality makes about race and
class and gender and poverty and
maleness et cetera or even violence can
be traced not to
black feminist ideology or theory but
could also be aligned with subcultural
violence theory from right races
criminology and sociologists would we
make the same claim that subculture
violence theory arthur by wolfgang and
ferracudi or the student miniature mamir
is in fact intersectionality uh so i
think that's my that's my response to
the feminists who make this claim is
the idea of black people studying the
relationship between racism and you know
sexism or sexual violence and uh poverty
is nothing new it's just that we've been
caught into a name because we've
attached it to a certain kind of
progressive language i mean certainly we
wouldn't be as silly to to think that
black people only focused on blackness
with no relationship our understanding
of say religion our nation right these
were the very debates that you had
between stokely carmichael and martin
luther king the role of poverty and
militarism right location in the
application of racism so the idea that
black people have never thought in
multiple terms and only thought of
blackness is a part of the
intersectional hysterography that i find
is false but more importantly i think
that the people claiming that
black male studies or even my work is
trying to reappropriate
intersectionality are sorely mistaken
because what i'm saying is we've always
thought in expansive terms and only when
we started talking about racial identity
in the post-civil rights era when we're
thinking about things like
discrimination and not colonialism does
become a question of how we're
identifying certain parts black male
studies is making the argument that
black men
aren't so much of an identity as a
caricaturized population so if you think
about this from the aspect of genocide
studies right would we say that jewish
men in the holocaust had a male
privilege because they were the victims
of extermination say first because we
know in genocides generally you have a
gender-saddle moment where you kill
civilian age men 15 to 55 and you pursue
root and branch killings it's basically
the pattern of 20th century genocidal
violence
is there male privilege there because
they were the first victims you see it
almost seems silly if not offensive to
suggest people who were targeted for
discrimination and elimination
fundamentally have privileges amongst
themselves but when we talk about black
people we seem to be able to attribute
all forms of privilege intentionality
and agency even under the most degrading
conditions so intersectionality wants to
look at say poverty people who are mired
in in situations of catastrophe and
violence and then point out that the
people who commit violence because they
lack employment education
social mobility etc are emphasizing our
acting on male privilege see to me that
seems nonsensical because when you look
at the antecedents that cause violence
intersectionality comes up short in
terms of what it perceives so to say
that a view or a theory that's looking
at social determinants of violence what
causes intra-group violence what causes
dehumanization
is the same things as the categories
that could be reduced down to maleness
and blackness sorely misunderstand the
depth of the complexity of oppression
and can you say a little bit about the
ways in which kind of black male
identity has been caricatured as you
said and
used to
sort of stigmatize and create these
harmful stereotypes you talk about hyper
masculinity hypersexuality in your work
no absolutely i think i think there's a
few things one is that black male
studies is looking at black men as a
population not necessarily an enduring
identity so
when i say that what i mean to convey is
when you look at historical processes of
genocide low-level conflict or even
racial conflicts throughout the world
throughout the 19th and 20th century
what you find are caricatures of
racialized men you see this in the
holocaust with nazis propaganda it was
jewish men who were thought to be devils
and animals and beasts you fair you find
very few hardly any references to women
or have women depicted in that way you
see the same thing during 1973 ethnology
because ethnology was a study of the
organization and hierarchy of races
based on the status of their men you see
all kinds of caricatures and writings
about black men as demons animals beasts
snakes etc as a representation of the
lowly nature and the evil that this that
the black race helped so given that
black men then epitomized in our modern
day this process of racial
characterization that legitimated
violence genocidal violence sometimes
and really do mark the process of
dehumanization so today we see this with
black men in terms of the threat they
pose to women and children in their own
group we suddenly we always look to
really decontextualize statistics of
domestic violence in the black community
are homicides talk about how violent
black men are and by effect how causally
violent black masculinity is we see this
in arguments about black men not
succeeding in in universities and
colleges pursuing their uh street life
rather than you know a life of books and
higher reflection all of this is based
not on the fact that we're actually
observing sociological phenomena but
we're using decadent racist theories
which hold that black men have lower iqs
their right counterparts and their
female counterpart to explain why we
think they turn to a culture and
practice of deviance hypersexuality
hyper masculinity these ideas that black
men are not balanced they're not mature
they're not developed that they're
always in some excess be it predatory or
be it savage and primitive that explains
why they have such a lowly position in
terms of criminality deviance and
downward mobility compared to their
female counterpart in whites these
theories are trying to explain why
populations don't have the same status
of civility and humanity that others do
and when we frame it merely as a problem
of identity i think we often miss the
historical processes that are involved
not only with black men as a specific
case study but racialized men generally
throughout the history of imperialism
colonialism and patriarchal dominance
so one of the
approaches to studying
race that does employ this kind of
historical method to some extent and the
kind of looking at material conditions
and not just at the kind of ideas of
identity that can become a bit rarefied
is critical race theory yes yes what do
you make of the fact that the right is
so afraid of school children and
university students learning about
critical race theory and on the other
hand what do you make of liberals
defending critical race theory as they
understand it yes the question is do
they really understand why yes yes well
i'll start with the latter question
first
liberals defend critical race theory
because they identify critical race
theory largely intersectionality they
see critical race theory as an
invitation to discuss and form
coalitions with certain members of
minority populations as i've pointed out
in my work and even through the research
of other scholars
those relationships and coalitions are
contingent largely on a broad
understanding of feminist ideology and
large are largely exclusive of men of
racial and ethnic backgrounds so
the intersectional idea that they have
of critical race theory
is one that furthers what they take to
be reformism and maintains the core
tenets of liberalism critical race
theory from the racial realist tradition
the tradition solidified by people like
derek bell linda greene kenneth nunn
richard delganos jane stefanczyk right
these scholars are making vastly
different arguments where they're
criticizing liberalism where they're
criticizing the very ability of white
liberals to understand and actually
participate in revolutionary anti-racist
practices are fundamentally challenged
the organization of society given that
it's ordained by the rule of law that's
why their work reads as much more
antagonistic to the liberal tradition uh
in gary peeler's book race consciousness
he actually makes this claim very clear
that to the white liberal the white
supremacists and the black nationalists
who's fighting white supremacy are
basically the same because the
evaluation of whether or not one is
racist or nationalistic isn't on whether
or not they're fighting injustice or
justice but whether or not they take the
race consciousness the race
characteristic like blackness or
whiteness to be a fundamental part of
their identity and their political
motivations well if you're looking at
black nationalists who take blackness
seriously precisely because it stands
outside of a white supremacist logic
then the white liberal looks at them and
says they're just as bad as the kkk
that's killing lynch and murdering
people but if you're looking at black
nationalism within a structural and
material basis then you're saying well
this grew as a response to the
oppressive conditions that white
liberals are safe from the complacent in
that allow black people to be killed
oppressed lynched etc and that's going
to be the biggest difference between how
black intellectuals and black radicals
understand their position within a white
supremacist empire logic or society
versus how white liberals who very much
stand on the sidelines and comment on
the moral whiteness of the people
participating in the conflict evaluate
the situation now conservatives are
quite different story because
conservatives especially in the united
states um fundamentally believe that the
values the structure and the empire that
makes up the united states are correct
and ordained by god so america is
the providence of god's will so to speak
uh it is the promise and will for
civilization to be led by that country
and by the set of values that
established it critical race theorists
will never be popular with conservatives
any more than black people will be
popular with white supremacists uh the
idea that the conservative has
is that teaching anti-patriotic ideas
the history of racism the history of
slavery the processes of colonialism the
role that capitalism has as being
infused with the bodies and bloods of
black people those are unacceptable
conversations because it
sullies it stains the ability of the
white nation to believe that it was
truly in the right so those
conversations aren't to be debated
they're to be censored so the rights
approach to censoring critical race
theory is largely a project that started
years ago even when i had to blow up at
texas a m where the right understood
that american colleges and american
campuses were actually breeding grounds
for what they take to be left this
ideology really they frame leftism as
marxism but nonetheless they see this as
running throughout feminism and
throughout critical race theory and
black studies so their approach which is
logical if you're a white supremacist or
you want to maintain the kind of
sanctity of the american republic is
let's start making these about what
we're teaching in schools universities
and colleges and to do that they said
we're going to start banning
conversations about black history in
primary school education so that means
that when people go to college there's
not going to be a push for it and we're
going to start censoring and punishing
state institutions that are going to
utilize state money and state funds to
teach these radical black ideologies now
the effect of that of course is there's
going to be a collective forgetting
of the kinds of progress that we think
that black studies or the election would
obama even if you're a good liberal or
even conversations about race have done
to move white people from say the
moderate uh center to the progressive
left
but because there's such a strong
reaction now one of the things that
people misunderstand about critical race
theory is that the tax on critical race
theory and the censorship of critical
race theory also expands the platform
for the right so now it becomes okay to
be racist it becomes okay to believe in
american imperialism and a romantic
american you know colonial empire legacy
very much like britain's right pass
britannica so these now that these
things are okay you're going to see more
and more resistance because it's going
to grow and it's going to you know
fertilize an intellectual culture where
white people are going to feel quite
secure
in both upholding and defending a
version of whiteness that's linked to
genocide's enslavement and the
continuing murder of black people in the
united states so in some ways both the
conservatives and the liberals for their
own personal reasons misunderstandable
critical race theories of course
of course but in in all honesty
most of the most of the engagements that
i've seen
about black thought both in the united
states by white liberals and in the uk
isn't based on them reading black people
you know one of one of the i think one
of the most
uh embarrassing and racist aspects of
how
people are approaching this question of
critical race theory or even
decoloniality or even black male studies
for that is that says they they don't
find themselves compelled to actually
read black authors so much of what they
understand on both the right and the
left as critical race theory comes from
pop culture the ability of black
thinkers to you know mobilize their
ideas on radio waves and on youtube you
know the the celebrity culture of the
united states is really a marker for who
white liberals are listening to not a
marker of who's doing the most rigorous
research that can be verified and
validated time after time the weakness
of that is that since the standards of
black intellectual acceptance are so
vastly different from white intellectual
acceptance which is based on research
peer review etc is that you're trying to
basically convince and sell your ideas
to a white liberal audience for their
adoption and that's going to be vastly
distant from what working-class black
people actually believe and how
working-class black people who suffer
from police brutality oppression you do
the primary targets of racism and
discriminate and discrimination uh
actually experience the world
let's go back to liberals for a moment
and the reason why they find
critical race theory or the real concept
of critical race theory may be hard to
accept i know this is a quote that's
often taken out of context by derek bell
but in some ways it reflects this idea
that
the very structures institutions legal
frameworks of the united states have
racism somehow inbuilt in them and so
sort of getting rid of that is not very
realistic unless you kind of undo the
whole institutional structure yes
i guess the question that
liberals might ask is like okay what do
we do with this diagnosis like if we
still want to somehow
make society less racist improve the
livelihood
and the quality of life of black people
in america and
in the uk
is anything short of undoing our
institutions
you know kind of pointless what are the
solutions well to me to be quite honest
with you it it depends on their true
understanding of the diagnosis right
many people evaluate bell's claim of
racial realism which is really the kind
of product of his racism is permanent
thesis um merely as a
rhetorical and pessimistic doctrine
but i would i would urge people to
really read what he's saying because
he's utilizing semi-colonial analysis
he's arguing that black people in the
united states are basically an
internalized colony who are economically
exploited and never fully participate or
are or have the guarantees of civil and
human rights
if you take that picture of reality
then it would seem that people that are
meant to be used for labor are are
deemed expendable for your political
projects and interests of course they
wouldn't be ever able to be fully
incorporated into the republic
now other scholars like jim sedania and
felicia prado have made similar
diagnoses looking at the evaluation or
the construction of hierarchies within
white supremacist capitalistic societies
right with capitalist surplus they've
come to the exact same conclusion and
they're using economics and psychology
to not only talk about the mindset that
dominant groups have of the out group
but also how hierarchies are constantly
built up and reified both in terms of
ideology and belief systems and in terms
of of capital acquisition so if you
think about a world where the dominant
end group in the case of the united
states and the uk white people will
construct their identity and organize
their society to extract resources from
those people who are poor to sustain the
group their own group's interests in
existence
then one would ask the question well how
then do you undo that if you don't undo
the structures of economics education
government et cetera that keep these
dynamics alive so i i often think that
the the white liberal
and and the progressive
believe so strongly in the in the moral
force of their ideas that they overlook
the material they overlook what the
social scientific evidence points them
to and because that's such a fate that
they don't want to endure having their
world undone
they say well it becomes impossible or
fatalistic but we have to think of it in
this way black people have endured
enslavement they've been through several
acts of genocide when we look throughout
africa and the diaspora and they still
struggle against these colonial
neocolonial apparatus they fought
against apartheid and brought about a
post-apartheid so the question of what
can be done or a solution doesn't seem
to be a problem for the people who are
oppressed it seems to be a problem for
the consciousness of the people who want
to endure the same economic and
political privileges of a system built
on unjust enrichment in relationship to
a group of people who are trying to tear
it down precisely because those
structures bring about oppression
suffering in tyranny so when we ask that
larger question about what's to be done
i think we really have to kind of humble
ourselves next to the traditions of
struggle and protest that every other
oppressed group seems to be able to find
and muster throughout several centuries
versus the white liberal who wants a
quick fix all
and and this is this dynamic right this
dynamic of violence this dynamic of
murder is exactly what black male
studies is highlighting black metal
studies starts from this kind of
pessimistic rendering it just asks a
different question whereas
intersectionality's political solution
is let's join together to the exclusion
of these nationalistic black men who
have been targeted by the state black
metal studies says well what is the
state's relationship to imposing
genocidal violence on members of the
certain racial or ethnic male group
because those usually are the most
radical groups why then do patriarchies
target racialized men so strongly if
they're actually part of the patriarchal
order themselves right notice all the
members of the black panther party black
civil rights organizations all the black
radicals of the 1960s and 70s were
killed by the state they were
criminalized by the state even with
black lives matter they created the term
black identity extremist they didn't go
arrest the black women they arrested and
killed black men
so ask yourself this question if black
men really do function as part of a
structure that recognizes and accept
them sex their maleness and their
patriarchal potential why does it take
such great efforts to criminalize and
demonize and kill them in every struggle
people have for racial revolution and
freedom
see the continuum that we have about
pessimism or derek bell's proclamation
is evidenced by the way that violence is
divvied out amongst oppressed people who
gets killed who dies why do you
sterilize black women you sterilize them
so you don't have more black men and
boys why do you fear black men and boys
well their militancy their revolutionary
thinking the pure threat that they
biologically and culturally have to the
dominance of the white race this is why
they pass anti-miscegenation laws why do
you have such negative caricatures of
muslim men black men jewish men armenian
men african men mexican men right
there's there's a repetitive process
here that we refuse to see because we're
so clouded by our politics by our
liberalism by our feminism by our gender
theory that we don't want to see that
the ways that people are dominated and
colonized and exterminated from the face
of the world
largely depends on how they eliminate
target and demonize their men and i
think that what we need now is a much
broader intellectual and empirical basis
for studying racism that moves us beyond
the question of whether or not white
people could be morally sueded out of
acting like white people and enacting
violence are even indifference towards
the suffering of everyone else
tommy kerry thank you very much thank
you
[Music]
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of art
and ideas at iai tv